Because technology sucks. That's the answer. Well, should we hop right into the episode with that being our goal tonight? I think so. Welcome to ADSP The Podcast, Episode 38, recorded on July 28, 2021. My name is Connor, and today with my co-host Bryce, we interview Sean Parent about the Adobe Software Technology Lab. Yeah, so I guess this is the third, I mean, we've had what, five episodes probably, but that was across two different recordings.
因为技术太烂了。这就是答案。好吧，我们要不要带着今晚的这个目标，直接切入本期节目？我觉得可以。欢迎来到 ADSP 播客第 38 期，录制于 2021 年 7 月 28 日。我是康纳（Connor），今天我和共同主持布莱斯（Bryce）一起，就 Adobe 软件技术实验室（Adobe Software Technology Lab）采访了肖恩·帕伦特（Sean Parent）。对，所以我想这是第三次，我的意思是，我们大概做过五期节目，但那是跨越了两次不同的录制。
So at this point, probably most of our listeners know who you are, Sean. But in case there are some people that have tuned in since the last time that you were on, maybe we'll start off by introduce, you can introduce yourself, just in case people are like, who is this Sean that has appeared out of nowhere? Okay. Yeah. So I'm Sean Parent. I'm a senior principal scientist at Adobe. I've been at Adobe off and on a little bit,
所以在这一点上，可能我们大部分听众都知道你是谁了，肖恩。但以防有一些人是从你上次上节目之后才开始收听的，也许我们可以从介绍开始，你可以自我介绍一下，以防有人在想：这个突然冒出来的肖恩是谁？好的。好的，我是肖恩·帕伦特。我是 Adobe 的高级首席科学家。我在 Adobe 断断续续待了，
I guess, for over 25 years. Started on the Photoshop team and most recently, I've been working with the Photoshop team and I'm restarting Adobe Software Technology Lab, which we'll talk more about in a bit here. Before Adobe, I was at Apple for five years. I worked on QuickTry GX and then the transition to PowerPC. And in the middle, somewhere close to the middle of my Adobe career, I took a year and went to Google and worked on Chrome OS and then flamed out and came back to Adobe.
我想，有 25 年多了。最初在 Photoshop 团队，最近，我一直在和 Photoshop 团队合作，并且我正在重新启动 Adobe 软件技术实验室，我们待会儿会详细聊这个。在 Adobe 之前，我在苹果待了五年。我从事过 QuickDraw GX，然后是向 PowerPC 的过渡。在中间，差不多接近我 Adobe 生涯的中期，我请了一年假去了谷歌，在 Chrome OS 团队工作，然后铩羽而归，又回到了 Adobe。
So that's who I am. All right, so I think it was episode 16 or 17 was one of the first ones we had you on. And I believe you did talk about what was it, the eight-year period with Alex Stepanov and was it Paul McJones? Where you had the initial ST Lab. But like maybe you can recount briefly sort of that period of time and you just sort of nonchalantly said that you're bringing it back um which is like it's it's with dave abrahams yeah well you took away his thunder bryce not gonna cut that out uh no so um uh uh yeah so this came about i don don't know, 2001 maybe.
这就是我。好的，我想第 16 期或第 17 期是我们最早邀请你上节目的其中一期。我记得你确实谈到了，是什么来着，和亚历山大·斯捷潘诺夫（Alex Stepanov）以及保罗·麦克琼斯（Paul McJones）共事的八年时期？你们当时有了最初的 ST 实验室。但也许你可以简要回顾一下那段时期，而且你刚刚云淡风轻地说你要把它带回来，嗯，这就像，而且是和戴夫·亚伯拉罕斯（Dave Abrahams）一起，对。好吧，你抢了戴夫的风头，布莱斯，这段可不能剪掉啊。哦，不，所以……嗯……嗯……是的，这大概是……我不知道，2001 年吧。
Alex Stepanoff came to Adobe and gave a talk. And after his talk, it was on STL. For people who don't know, Alex Stepanoff is the person who created the standard template library for C++. And he came and gave a talk at Adobe and after his talk he and I started chatting and at the time he was a vice president at Compaq which was in transition they had just been acquired by Hewlett Packard. And so he was kind of sliding back to HP he had actually created STL while working at HP Labs. And we were chatting about work that I was doing,
亚历山大·斯捷潘诺夫来到 Adobe 做了一场演讲。他的演讲结束后，内容是关于 STL 的。对于不知情的人来说，亚历山大·斯捷潘诺夫就是为 C++ 创建标准模板库（Standard Template Library）的人。他来 Adobe 做了一场演讲，演讲结束后，我和他聊了起来。当时他是康柏（Compaq）的副总裁，而康柏正处于转型期，刚刚被惠普（Hewlett Packard）收购。所以他当时有点要回到惠普的意思，他实际上是在惠普实验室工作时创建了 STL。我们当时在聊我正在做的工作，
and we ended up spending a long evening in my office just talking about engineering stuff. And at the end, he said, you know, this is amazing. I would love to get back into engineering, and I haven't had a conversation like this in a long time. And I said, well, why don't you? I would love to get back into engineering and I haven't had a conversation like this in a long time and I said well, why don't you and He just kind of shrugged it off But a couple weeks later he called me up and said, you know
我们最后在我办公室度过了一个漫长的夜晚，一直在聊工程方面的事情。最后，他说：“你知道，这太棒了。我很想重新回到工程领域，我很久没有进行过这样的对话了。”我说：“好吧，你为什么不呢？我很想重新回到工程领域，我很久没有进行过这样的对话了，我说，你为什么不呢？”
I gave it a lot of thought and I don't want to be a manager anymore. I want to be an engineer so is there a position at Adobe? And there's a bit of a long story here because he did join Adobe. I was not able to get him to join. I was working in Adobe's research group and I was not able to get him into Adobe's research group. So he joined a different group, one of our shared technology groups, and found it a bit frustrating. There was a bit of a mismatch there between somebody who's kind of a very senior researcher and mathematician and a group that's just slogging through a bunch of
他只是耸耸肩敷衍过去了。但几周后他打电话给我说：“你知道，我仔细考虑过了，我不想再当经理了。我想成为一名工程师，所以 Adobe 有这样的职位吗？”这中间有一个比较长的故事，因为他确实加入了 Adobe。我当时没能让他加入。我在 Adobe 的研究小组工作，我没能让他进入 Adobe 的研究小组。所以他加入了一个不同的组，我们共享的技术组之一，然后他觉得有点受挫。作为一个非常高级的研究员和数学家，与一个正忙于处理一堆漏洞的团队之间，存在一些不匹配。
bugs. And the result of that you find, I gave this story at Alex's retirement party. So there's a video of that online. Maybe you can link it in the show notes. But the end result was, I thought Alex was going to quit. He was getting frustrated, but he insisted that no, he thought that the job was worthwhile and he was enjoying it and he was going to stick it out and work with this team. And about two weeks after we had that conversation, he called me up and said, guess what? And I said, you're quitting. He's like, no, they fired me. And so
而这产生的结果是——我在亚历山大的退休派对上讲过这个故事。所以网上有那个视频。也许你们可以在节目简介里放个链接。但最终结果是，我以为亚历山大要辞职了。他当时开始感到沮丧，但他坚持认为，不，他认为这份工作很有价值，他很享受，他打算坚持下去并与这个团队一起工作。在我们进行那次对话大约两周后，他打电话给我说：“你猜怎么着？”我说：“你要辞职了。”他说：“不，他们解雇我了。”所以
he had been fired from Adobe. And I scrambled and Greg Gilley, who I think I mentioned. I did spend like 40 minutes last time trying to find that video clip of him rambling on stage. It took me a while, but I did find it. You didn't find it? I did find it. I did find it. No, you did find it. Yeah, yeah. It's hilarious.
他被 Adobe 解雇了。然后我手忙脚乱地去找格雷格·吉利（Greg Gilley），我想我提到过他。我上次确实花了大约 40 分钟试图找到他站在舞台上喋喋不休的那个视频片段。我花了好一会儿，但我确实找到了。你没找到吗？我找到了。我确实找到了。不，你找到了。对，对。太搞笑了。
I hope people that listen to the podcast. You can tell Bryce does not listen to the podcast. You're a busy guy. I understand. So, so in any case, I went to Greg who, uh, uh, Greg was, uh, like, you know, director of, uh, uh, digital imaging. So he had, had Photoshop and had a bunch of products under him, different org than I was in and different organization than Alex was in. Um, uh, but I knew Greg well, and I went to Greg and I said, so this guy than Alex was in. But I knew Craig well and I went to Craig and I said so this guy Alex Stepanoff I know you probably don't even know who he is but an amazing individual he was just
我希望听播客的人……你可以看出布莱斯根本不听播客。你是个大忙人，我理解。所以，不管怎样，我去找格雷格，嗯……格雷格当时是……呃，数字影像部门的总监。所以他手下有 Photoshop 和一堆产品，跟我所在的组织不同，跟亚历山大所在的组织也不同。嗯……但我跟格雷格很熟，我去找格雷格说，嗯，所以我跟格雷格很熟，我去找格雷格说：所以这家伙——比亚历山大所在的部门还要不同。但我跟克雷格很熟，我去找克雷格说，所以这家伙亚历山大·斯捷潘诺夫，我知道你可能甚至不知道他是谁，但他是一个了不起的人，他刚刚被解雇了，你需要重新雇佣他。
fired and and you need to hire him back. And Craig was like I can't do that, it's another organization that would be going against another VP, I can't hire this guy back. And I said, well, I'll put it this way, I said, if he goes, then I go with him. And so why don't you at least take the time and go out to lunch? And have lunch with the man and see what you think. And so he went to lunch with Alex and came back and called me and said, you know, come to my office. And I came in and he said, you know, god damn you.
克雷格当时就说：“我不能这么做，那是另一个组织，这会违背另一个副总裁的意愿，我不能重新雇佣这个人。”我说：“好吧，我这么说吧，我说，如果他走，那我也跟他一起走。所以你为什么不至少花点时间和这个人吃个午饭？跟他吃个午饭，看看你的想法。”于是他和亚历山大去吃了午饭，回来后给我打电话说：“你知道，来我办公室。”我走进去了，他说：“你知道，该死的。”
He said, I'm going to hire this guy back. And he said, but here's the deal. If I hire him back, you have to manage him. And so out of that, Alex and I started Adobe Software Technology Lab, which was, the name came from Hewlett-Packard Software Technology Lab, which is actually, everybody always thinks that STL stands for Standard Template Library, or some people think it's Stepanoff and Lee, because it was Alex Stepanoff and Meng Li who wrote the initial paper. But it actually, STL comes from Software Technology Lab, which is where Alex was working at HP. And so we created a group, Software Technology Lab, and it was within Adobe's digital imaging organization. And the charter of the group
他说：“我要把这家伙重新雇回来。”然后他说：“但条件是，如果我把他雇回来，你得管理他。”从那以后，亚历山大和我创立了 Adobe 软件技术实验室（Adobe Software Technology Lab）。这个名字来源于惠普软件技术实验室（Hewlett-Packard Software Technology Lab），事实上，每个人总是以为 STL 代表标准模板库（Standard Template Library），或者有些人认为它是 Stepanoff 和 Lee 的缩写，因为是亚历山大·斯捷潘诺夫和孟李（Meng Li）写了最初的论文。但实际上，STL 来自软件技术实验室，那是亚历山大在惠普工作的地方。所以我们创建了一个团队，软件技术实验室，它隶属于 Adobe 的数字影像组织。该团队的章程
was to improve software engineering practice at Adobe, but we also thought that to do that you kind of had to do it industry-wide. And we defined practice to be distinct from process, meaning that we were concerned with what engineers wrote when they sat down at the keyboard, not with things like how they ran a scrum or whether or not they were following an agile process or anything along those lines. It was concerned about what do they actually type when they sit down and write code. And we did that with a three-prong approach. So part of it was education. And so Alex was teaching a class at Adobe, and that eventually led to the publication of Elements of besides education, we had libraries and tooling.
是改善 Adobe 的软件工程实践，但我们也认为，要做到这一点，你必须在整个行业范围内推动它。我们将“实践”（practice）定义为不同于“流程”（process），这意味着我们关注的是工程师坐在键盘前时所编写的代码，而不是诸如他们如何运行 scrum、是否遵循敏捷流程或任何类似的事情。它关注的是他们坐下来写代码时实际敲击的键盘内容。我们通过三管齐下的方法来实现这一点。一部分是教育。所以亚历山大当时在 Adobe 上课，这最终导致了《编程原本》（Elements of Programming）的出版。除了教育，我们还有库和工具。
And so that created something called the Adobe Source Libraries, which are still kicking around. They've kind of moved into my own domain, which is stlab.cc. And they're still available up on GitHub and still in wide use inside of Adobe. But that's a set of libraries that do some interesting things that we could talk about at some point. And then part of it was research. So we had ongoing collaborations with universities,
于是这就创造了名为 Adobe 来源库（Adobe Source Libraries）的东西，它们至今仍然存在。它们已经转移到了我自己的领域，即 stlab.cc。它们仍然可以在 GitHub 上找到，并且在 Adobe 内部仍然被广泛使用。但这是一套做了一些有趣事情的库，我们可以在某个时候讨论一下。然后另一部分是研究。所以我们与各大高校保持着持续的合作，
including Indiana University, where Andrew Lemstein was at, and Texas A&M, where Bjarne Stroustrup was at. And we brought in Paul McJones who, for people who don't know, Paul's been around for a long time. He worked with John Backus at IBM. He worked on the module 3 language, System R, which was an early relational database. John Backus, for those that don't know, I think that's the individual who was behind Fortran? Individual who was behind Fortran, Turing Award winner. If you've ever heard of EB&F as a way to describe grammars, that's Bacchus as the B in EB&F.
包括安德鲁·莱姆斯坦（Andrew Lemshtein）所在的印第安纳大学，以及比亚尔尼·斯特劳斯特鲁普（Bjarne Stroustrup）所在的德克萨斯农工大学。我们引进了保罗·麦克琼斯（Paul McJones），对于不了解的人来说，保罗在这一行已经很久了。他曾在 IBM 与约翰·巴科斯（John Backus）共事。他参与了 Module 3 语言、System R（一个早期关系数据库）的工作。对于不了解约翰·巴科斯的人来说，我认为他就是那个缔造了 Fortran 的人？缔造了 Fortran 的人，图灵奖得主。如果你听说过作为描述语法方法的 EBNF，那么 EB&F 中的 B 就是指巴科斯。
So, yes. Quite prolific. One of the greats in the industry. And another person from Adobe's research team was Matt Marcus and he also represented Adobe on the C++ standards committee at the time and then Foster Brereton who was now a very senior engineer on the Photoshop team but he and I had worked together on the Photoshop team he had been my intern for a while on Photoshop and he joined the. So kind of the peak of the group, there were five of us. And we had a good eight-year run, and then had kind of a spectacular, very
所以，是的。著作颇丰。业内巨匠之一。来自 Adobe 研究团队的另一个人是马特·马库斯（Matt Marcus），他当时还代表 Adobe 参加了 C++ 标准委员会；然后是福斯特·布雷尔顿（Foster Brereton），他现在是 Photoshop 团队的资深高级工程师，但他和我以前在 Photoshop 团队一起工作过，他曾在 Photoshop 做过我一段时间的实习生，然后他加入了……所以在这个团队的鼎盛时期，我们有五个人。我们度过了美好的八年，然后在八年结束时经历了一次非常引人注目、充满政治色彩的崩盘，这导致我辞职了，这就是我后来去谷歌待了一段时间的原因。
political flame-out at the end of the eight years, and that led to me resigning, and that's how I ended up at Google for a while. And Alex and Paul left. Alex went to A9. Paul retired. At that point, what led to the flameout was actually Adobe went through a round of layoffs, and Matt Marcus had been laid off. And it was a decision that I had absolutely no say in um and i thought was was a very wrong decision i think i'm maybe i knew this but i forgot that the reason that you left adobe
亚历山大和保罗都离开了。亚历山大去了 A9。保罗退休了。当时，导致崩盘的导火索其实是 Adobe 经历了一轮裁员，马特·马库斯被裁了。这是一个我完全没有发言权的决定，而且我认为这是一个非常错误的决定。我想——也许我知道这一点，但我忘了你离开 Adobe 的原因……
uh was because of that um yeah i don't think i knew that but and it coincided with the flaming out of the ST Lab. Yep, yep. At that point, Foster had already slid over back to the Photoshop team. So he was kind of spared the whole implosion of the team. Here's a question, Sean. You were only at Google for a year, right? Yeah, just over a year. Do you regret having left? Because you came back to Adobe, so obviously it was the right place.
是因为那个……嗯，我想我以前不知道这一点，但它恰好与 ST 实验室的崩盘同时发生。是的，是的。当时，福斯特已经转回了 Photoshop 团队。所以他算是免于经历了整个团队的土崩瓦解。有一个问题，肖恩。你在谷歌只待了一年，对吧？是的，刚满一年。你后悔离开吗？因为你回到了 Adobe，所以显然这里才是正确的地方。
But do you regret having left or was it just sort of like you needed a break? And even if it maybe wasn't the right long-term decision, you felt that, like, in hindsight, it was a good thing at the time. Good thing for you. It was a good thing for me. You know, I don't see how I could have stayed at Adobe under the circumstances. I came back kind of under very different circumstances. The promise at Google was, you know, they gave me a great pitch that they were creating a new OS from the ground up, and it was a web-oriented OS, and they had read a bunch of my papers, and they liked my ideas, and they wanted me to inject my ideas into this new OS.
但你后悔离开吗？还是说这就像是你需要休息一下？而且即使从长期来看这可能不是一个正确的决定，你觉得，事后看来，当时这是一件好事。对你来说是一件好事。这对我是件好事。你知道，我看不出在那种情况下我怎么还能留在 Adobe。我回来时的情况完全不同了。谷歌给出的承诺是，你知道，他们向我极力推销说他们正在从头开始创建一个新的操作系统，这是一个以网页为导向的操作系统，他们读过我的一些论文，喜欢我的想法，并希望我将自己的想法注入到这个新操作系统中。
How do you say no to something like that? The reality was the new OS was Chrome OS, which isn't really a new OS. It's Linux with a Chrome browser tightly bonded to it. I don't really think the manager who I was speaking with had actually read my papers. He had read some of my blog posts, which meant we agreed on the problems,
你怎么能对这样的事情说不呢？现实情况是，这个新操作系统就是 Chrome OS，它并不是一个真正的操作系统。它是一个 Linux，紧密结合了一个 Chrome 浏览器。我真的不认为跟我谈话的那个经理真的读过我的论文。他读过我的一些博客文章，这意味着我们在问题上达成了共识，
but not necessarily the solutions. And so I was a bit of a mismatch with the team that I was hired into and was kind of going against the grain of both the team and Google. That said, I still very much believed in the vision of Chrome OS, and I'm still a fan of Chrome OS and kind of what it is and where it's at. I think it's an amazing product.
但对解决方案不尽然。因此，我与我被招进去的团队有些格格不入，有点逆着团队和谷歌的方向。话虽如此，我仍然非常坚信 Chrome OS 的愿景，我仍然是 Chrome OS 的粉丝，喜欢它的现状和发展方向。我认为这是一个了不起的产品。
So, yeah, I learned a lot. I got to work with some great people. Still have friends that I made at Google, but for me personally, it was not the right fit, and it was a painful environment to work in because I'm somebody who, if you give me a problem, I will kind of keep chewing at it and keep coming back to it and keep revisiting it and just keep kind of drilling down.
所以，是的，我学到了很多。我有机会和一些伟大的人共事。我至今仍保留着在谷歌结交的朋友，但就我个人而言，这并不适合我，而且那是一个令人痛苦的工作环境，因为我是那种人——如果你给我一个问题，我会一直琢磨它，不断回头看它，不断重新审视它，一直深入挖掘下去。
And I will, you know, if it's an interesting problem, I'll obsess about things for years and just kind of keep chipping away at them. And Google was not an environment that allowed for that. It was, you know, here's the highest priority problem. Get it done enough that it's not the highest priority problem. Move on to the next problem. And I don't switch tasks like that well.
而且我会，你知道，如果这是一个有趣的问题，我会纠结好几年，然后不断地去攻克它。而谷歌并不是一个允许这样做的环境。那是，你知道的，这就是最高优先级的问题。把它做到差不多就行，让它不再是最高优先级的问题。然后转向下一个问题。而我不擅长这样切换任务。
So it was not a good fit. From my point of view, it was an amazing year for you, Sean, because we're forgetting what came out of that year. Yeah. But that's where the That's a Rotate comes from, your time at Google. That is where That's a Rotate from. That was the long story of the C++ Seasoning Talk
所以这很不合拍。从我的角度来看，肖恩，对你来说这是神奇的一年，因为我们都忘了那一年诞生了什么。是的。但那正是 “That's a Rotate” 的出处，你呆在谷歌的那段时光。那正是 “That's a Rotate” 的出处。那是关于 C++ Seasoning 演讲的长篇故事，
is on A9 Videos. I went and gave it at Amazon when Alex was over at Amazon. And yes, so the back story on that, the code that I put up in the C++ Seasoning Talk is code from my very first code review at Google. Oh, wow. I did not know that part. Yeah, so at Google, you kind of have to earn gold stars. You have to, you know, get your readability certificate and your code review certificate. Even you had to? Even me. It doesn't matter how senior you are coming into the company.
它在 A9 视频网站上。亚历山大在亚马逊时，我去亚马逊做过这个演讲。是的，所以背后的故事是，我在 C++ Seasoning 演讲中展示的代码，其实是我在谷歌的第一次代码审查（code review）中的代码。哦，哇。我不知道还有这部分。是的，所以在谷歌，你得积攒小红星。你得，你知道的，获得可读性证书和代码审查证书。连你也需要？连我也需要。不管你进公司时的资历有多老。
So, you know, I joined the team and I'm the noogler. I've got to, you know, go through code reviews and I've got a mentor who's going to, you know, look over my shoulder during the code review to make sure I'm doing the code review correctly according to Google's guidelines. And I was given this piece of code to review. And when I do a code review, the first thing I always look at is, are there any loops? And if so, what are the loops doing? And this was a very long function with a whole bunch of loops in it that I'm reviewing. And I'm like, what in the world is this thing? oh, I see, this is a, it's basically a find if followed by rotate. And really, that was the start of it. But if you look through the rest of it, it was a find if followed by a slide,
所以，你知道，我加入了团队，我是个新人（noogler）。我必须，你知道的，经历代码审查，而且我有一个导师，他会在代码审查期间盯着我的肩膀，确保我按照谷歌的指南正确地进行代码审查。我被分配了这段代码来进行审查。当我做代码审查时，我首先看的是：有没有循环？如果有，循环在做什么？而我正在审查的是一个非常长的函数，里面有一堆循环。我在想：这到底是什么东西？哦，我明白了，这是一个，基本上是一个 find_if 后面跟着 rotate。真的，这就是开始。但如果你仔细看剩下的部分，它是一个 find_if 后面跟着 slide，
which is a rotate going one way or the other. And then wrapped up with a transform at the end. And so, you know, I spent an evening kind of digging through this and figuring it out. And then wrote that up in my comment and was like, okay, so this whole big massive code I'm reviewing is find if, pair of rotates, transform, done. And the person whose code it was was like, this isn't a rotate. I was like, oh no, this is a rotate.
也就是向左或向右旋转（rotate）的 rotate。最后用一个 transform 收尾。所以，你知道，我花了一个晚上来钻研并弄清楚这一点。然后把这些写进我的评论里，心想：好吧，我正在审查的这整个庞大代码实际上就是 find_if、一对 rotate、transform，搞定。而代码的拥有者却说：“这不是 rotate。”我说：“哦，不，这就是 rotate。”
It's an inefficient quadratic rotate, but it's a rotate. And he was like, no, it isn't a rotate. I was like, oh no, this is a rotate. It's an inefficient quadratic rotate, but it's a rotate. And he was like, no, it's not a rotate. It's doing something else. And I'm like, nope. May not be what you intended to do, but what the code is doing is a rotate. And it took me a fair amount of time,
这是一个低效的二次方 rotate，但它就是 rotate。而他却说：“不，它不是 rotate。”我说：“哦，不，这就是 rotate。这是一个低效的二次方 rotate，但它就是 rotate。”而他却说：“不，它不是 rotate。它在做别的事情。”我说：“不，这可能不是你的本意，但代码正在做的事情就是 rotate。”我花了相当长的时间，
kind of conversations on and off for two weeks with the individual who wrote the code to convince him that yes in fact it was a rotate and that a rotate would be more efficient in this case and shorten up his code and I convinced him and he was like okay I see, I understand you're right, this is so much
断断续续地跟写代码的那个人聊了两个星期，才说服他：是的，事实上这就是 rotate，而且在这种情况下使用 rotate 会更高效，还能缩短他的代码。我终于说服了他，他当时就说：“好吧，我明白了，我懂了，你是对的，这好太多了。”
better. And so he rewrote the code and checked it in, or put it back in for the code review. Said, you know, Sean convinced me this is correct. And my mentor said, no, you can't submit that. It was better the way it was before. Nobody knows what a rotate is, and that's too tricky. And, you know, I argued that argument and lost. And so the code got checked into Chrome OS and Chromium. And the reason why I'm able to put that code on my slides is because Chromium is open sourced. And so that code went into the open source project and it is now part of the public record. The code actually does use rotate now.
于是他重构了代码并提交了，或者说重新放回代码审查中。他说：“你知道，肖恩说服了我，这是对的。”而我的导师却说：“不，你不能提交这个。还是以前那样比较好。没人知道 rotate 是什么，这太难懂了。”然后，你知道的，我据理力争却失败了。所以这段代码被合入了 Chrome OS 和 Chromium。我之所以能把这段代码放在我的幻灯片上，是因为 Chromium 是开源的。所以这段代码进入了开源项目，现在成了公开记录的一部分。这段代码现在确实使用 rotate 了。
I think that's an exclusive we just got there. Did they change it to use the rotate after the talk? After he gave you talk, Sean? As far as I know, yeah. I wonder if there's a long story of that getting back to the team or the manager and the person that wrote the code initially. Probably they had moved on at that point, but it would be so funny if they were still there
我觉得我们刚刚独家爆料了。他们在你做完演讲之后才改成使用 rotate 的吗？在你做完演讲之后，肖恩？据我所知，是的。我在想，这个消息传回团队、经理以及最初写代码的那个人，中间是不是有一段漫长的故事。可能他们当时已经转岗了，但如果他们当时还在，那就太搞笑了，
and then this story is just getting retold and the story of it getting told is getting retold and they're like you know what we should we should this is uh we got to go and change that code um well connor obviously after this after this recording you're gonna have to go find that code and do the git blame on it and see if you've changed it to a rotate and when. Yeah, you know, I would, you know, I try not to, just because, you know, I work on a product that's been around for 30 years. So a lot of times I do the git blame. I'm like, who the F wrote that?
然后这个故事被反复讲述，故事的讲述又被反复讲述，他们会觉得：你知道吗，我们应该——这真是……我们得去把那代码改了。好吧，康纳，显然在这个录音结束后，你得去找出那段代码，用 git blame 查一下，看看他们是什么时候把它改成 rotate 的。是的，你知道，我……我尽量不去这么做，仅仅是因为，你知道，我维护的一个产品已经有 30 年历史了。所以很多时候我用 git blame。我会想：到底是谁写的这破代码？
And I'm like, oh, I did. Darn it, okay. So yeah, I mean. Yeah, I think we've all been there where we're staring at some code and, yeah, who did this? And then you find out and it's like, oh, it was me from two years ago. Ah, that's impressive. I didn't know what I was doing two years ago. I can't believe that works.
然后我想：哦，是我自己。该死，好吧。所以，是的。是的，我想我们都有过这种经历：盯着某段代码心想，天呐，这是谁写的？然后你一查发现：哦，原来是两年前的我。啊，真令人印象深刻。我两年前根本不知道自己在干什么。真不敢相信这居然能跑通。
Yeah. Yeah. from being a, you know, managing a research team with some world-class computer scientists on it to kind of, you know, working as a nuclear with, you know, I would say a, you know, an organization that didn't care about your previous history. So that was a bit of a culture shock to slide into that. So where was I? Yeah, so that's what Software Technology Lab was. We had, you know, I think an amazing eight-year run. Like I said, the Adobe Source libraries are still in heavy use. I still have some ongoing university collaborations going with Jaco Yarve, who he was at Texas A&M, and now he's at, what is it?
从管理一个拥有世界级计算机科学家的研究团队，到作为一个新人（noogler）工作，面对一个……我会说，一个根本不在乎你过去历史的组织。所以进入这样的环境算是一次文化冲击。我刚才讲到哪了？是的，这就是软件技术实验室。我们度过了，我认为是极其美妙的八年。就像我说的，Adobe 来源库仍在被大量使用。我仍然与雅科·雅尔韦（Jako Yarve）保持着持续的大学合作，他以前在德克萨斯农工大学，现在在……叫什么来着？
I'm trying to blank on the name. We'll fill it in. It's a university in Finland. We worked on something called property models, which are within the library. And now I've got Dave Abrahams hooked on property models. And we wrote the book, published the book, Elements of Programming, which I think kind of had a huge influence on C++
我突然想不起名字了。我们待会儿补上。那是芬兰的一所大学。我们致力于研究一种叫做属性模型（property models）的东西，它们就在这个库里面。现在我把戴夫·亚伯拉罕斯也拉进了属性模型的坑里。我们写了这本书，出版了《编程原本》，我认为这本书对 C++ 产生了巨大的影响，
and formalizes the ideas of generic programming. Alex Stepanov is the person who created the term generic programming. I think, Bryce, you've said that that's the only book that you've read on C++, correct? The only programming book. Not the only book that I've read. Yeah, that's what I said, yeah. It's the only programming book that I've read, though. Yeah, and actually because I'm in the middle of the move,
并且将泛型编程（generic programming）的理念形式化了。亚历山大·斯捷潘诺夫就是创造“泛型编程”这个术语的人。我想，布莱斯，你曾说过这是你读过的唯一一本关于 C++ 的书，对吧？唯一的编程书。不是我读过的唯一一本书。对，我是这么说的，没错。不过它确实是我读过的唯一的编程书。是的，而且正因为我正在搬家，
I'm packing up all my books right now,, I'm tempted to get rid of half of them. Cause I got all these C plus plus books that I never read, but, uh, uh, I I'm obviously not going to get rid of my elements of programming copy, which, uh, was a, it was my like 20th birthday gift from my mentor Hartmut, uh, who just appeared in the office store on the day of my birthday and he's like here you should have this and uh then I read it and I was like yeah I should have this yep and it's uh the book is open source now too so it's uh or I don't know open source freely available uh you can you can look it up online and download it I don't know, open source, freely available. You can look it up online and download it. I didn't realize that Stepanov had coined the term generic programming.
我现在正在打包所有的书，我真想把它们扔掉一半。因为我有一堆从来没读过的 C++ 书籍，但是，我显然不会扔掉我的那本《编程原本》，那是我导师哈特穆特（Hartmut）在我 20 岁生日时送我的生日礼物，他当时直接出现在办公室里，在我生日那天说：“给你，这本书你该留着。”然后我读了之后觉得：“没错，我是该留着。”而且这本书现在也是开源的了，所以……或者我不知道这算不算开源，是免费获取的……你可以在网上查到并下载它。我以前没意识到“泛型编程”这个词是斯捷潘诺夫创造的。
You haven't seen my talk, The History of Generic Programming. I guess I have. Yes. Yep. Yep. We just went past the 30th year, the 30th anniversary of generic programming. And so I gave a talk because I thought it needed to be recognized. So I gave a talk on the history of generic programming.
你没看过我的演讲《泛型编程的历史》（The History of Generic Programming）。我想我看过吧。是的。对。我们刚刚走过泛型编程的第 30 个年头，即 30 周年纪念。所以我做了一个演讲，因为我觉得这需要被认可。所以我做了一个关于泛型编程历史的演讲。
Yeah, that's the one you gave at Pacific C++, right? Yep. So the big news is that STLab is back. Yeah, so STLab is back. Yeah, so ST Lab is back. This time it's Dave Abrahams, for people who don't know who Dave is. In the C++ community, Dave was very well known as a Boost contributor and somebody who had, along with Eric Niebler, they had a company,
对，那就是你在太平洋 C++ 大会上（Pacific C++）做的演讲，对吧？对。所以最大的新闻是 STLab 回归了。对，STLab 回归了。对，STLab 回归了。这一次是戴夫·亚伯拉罕斯，对于那些不知道戴夫是谁的人来说。在 C++ 社区中，戴夫作为 Boost 的贡献者非常知名，他与埃里克·尼布勒（Eric Niebler）一起拥有一家公司，
Boost Pro, which was a consulting firm around Boost. And Dave contributed many things to the standard library, and I think one of his key contributions, he gets a mention in my history of generic programming talk, was the formalism of the requirements for exception handling, the basic exception guarantees and the strong exception guarantees. That's from a paper that Dave published, which I think was was a very important piece of work. And then he kind of left the C++ community, I don't know, almost a decade ago, not too long after I had my run to Google, and went to Apple and is one of the creators of the Swift language. And then he created SwiftUI, and then he was most recently at Google
Boost Pro，这是一家围绕 Boost 的咨询公司。戴夫为标准库做出了许多贡献，我认为他最关键的贡献之一——他在我的泛型编程历史演讲中被提及——是异常处理需求的形式化，即基本的异常保证和强异常保证。那是来自戴夫发表的一篇论文，我认为这是一项非常重要的工作。然后他离开了 C++ 社区，我不知道，差不多是在我跑到谷歌后不久的近十年前，他去了苹果，是 Swift 语言的创造者之一。然后他创造了 SwiftUI，最近他曾在谷歌
working on Swift for TensorFlow, which you can look that up. It was a project that ran for about a year at Google recently, or it had Chris Lattner started it there. Chris Lattner is the person who created LLVM for people who don't know, and also he worked at Apple and is one of the creators of the Swift language. Chris left Google and then about a year later while Dave was working there, they cancelled the Swift for TensorFlow project. And I managed to snag Dave. And it came about at a good time for Adobe. Adobe's been pushing our products onto a lot more platforms. I think you're seeing that. We have Lightroom Mobile, Lightroom Web, Photoshop Mobile at this point. You'll see Photoshop appear on other platforms. And so our products are increasingly getting brought up on increasingly diverse environments.
从事 Swift for TensorFlow 的工作，你可以去查查。这是最近在谷歌运行了大约一年的一个项目，或者是由克里斯·拉特纳（Chris Lattner）在那里启动的。对于不知道的人来说，克里斯·拉特纳就是创造了 LLVM 的人，他也曾在苹果工作，是 Swift 语言的创造者之一。克里斯离开了谷歌，大约一年后，在戴夫工作期间，他们取消了 Swift for TensorFlow 项目。而我成功把戴夫挖了过来。这对 Adobe 来说是个好时机。Adobe 一直在将我们的产品推向更多平台。我想大家都有目共睹。我们现在有了 Lightroom Mobile、Lightroom Web、Photoshop Mobile。你会看到 Photoshop 出现在其他平台上。因此我们的产品越来越多地运行在日益多样化的环境中。
And one thing that we're struggling with is exploiting the hardware where we have an increasingly diverse landscape of what the hardware characteristics are. So kind of how do you code for that? And part of that is how do you code for that? Part of that is how do you deal with concurrency in a way that scales both up and down and is efficient in all configurations and doesn't cause a lot of bugs and problems. Right now concurrency is driving a lot of our quality issues.
而我们正在挣扎的一件事是如何利用硬件，因为我们所面对的硬件特征环境日益多样化。那么，你该如何为此编写代码呢？部分问题在于你如何为此编写代码。部分问题在于你如何以一种既能向上扩展又能向下扩展、在所有配置下都高效、且不会导致大量漏洞和问题的方式来处理并发。目前，并发问题正在导致我们大量的质量问题。
And they're not things that ThreatSanitizer will pick up. They're not hard race conditions. They're what I refer to as logical races. Their developer made an assumption that A will happen and then B, but sometimes it happens B then A. And so that generated some impetus to say maybe I could try to get out in front of the teams and blaze a path around concurrency and follow the same charter that we had for the old software technology lab of taking a three-prong approach through
这些都不是线程消毒剂（ThreadSanitizer）能挑出来的毛病。它们不是硬竞争条件（hard race conditions）。它们是我所称的逻辑竞争（logical races）。开发者假设 A 会发生，然后 B 发生，但有时会先发生 B 然后才是 A。因此，这产生了一种动力，让我觉得也许我可以尝试走到团队的前面，开辟一条关于并发的道路，并遵循我们老软件技术实验室的宗旨，采用三管齐下的方法，即通过
education, tooling, tooling in libraries, and research with university collaborations. And pull in Dave, and Dave has a lot of experience in this area and working on on memory safety which is closely related to concurrency issues and you know hopefully together we can we can make a dent in this and so so he's got permission. We kind of spun up the team. It's just the two of us at this point. We'll probably grow to three to five,
教育、工具、库中的工具，以及与高校合作的研究。并把戴夫拉进来，戴夫在这个领域以及内存安全（与并发问题密切相关）方面拥有丰富的经验，你知道，希望我们能携手取得突破，所以他得到了批准。我们算是在团队内部成立了这个小组。目前只有我们两个人。我们可能会发展到三到五人，
which is the old software technology lab peaked at five. I'd like to get in between there. We're looking at the problems that the teams are having and trying to figure out how we have an impact on them. And so we'll be restarting some classes soon. We're taking a bunch of notes and we're kind of identifying what are some of the key problem areas where we think we can come up with some solutions that can filter back down into the teams and have an impact. Is there a chance this is going to be like A9 Videos 2.0,
也就是老软件技术实验室的巅峰时期是五人。我想把人数控制在这个范围。我们在审视团队目前遇到的问题，并试图弄清楚如何对他们产生影响。因此我们很快会重新开课。我们正在做大量的笔记，并确定一些关键的问题领域，我们认为在这些领域可以提出一些解决方案，这些方案可以渗透回各个团队并产生影响。有没有可能这将成为 A9 视频的 2.0 版，
where they're going to get posted on YouTube at some point? I think so. We're getting a, you know, right now in the Valley, you know, in the industry, not just Silicon Valley, in the industry, hiring is very competitive. And Adobe has been growing very fast, even through the pandemic. In some ways, the pandemic's been, you know, Adobe is one of the companies that the pandemic's been good for, right? Every mom and pop shop now has to create their own website and get e-commerce online, and they're going to need, you know, Photoshop and Acrobat and our web creation tools, and they need analytics for their advertising and all of that and these are are all things all products that that adobe sells um uh so so because it's become competitive uh adobe tends not to have
它们会在某个时候被发布到 YouTube 上？我想是的。我们正在——你知道的，现在在硅谷，在整个行业里，不仅仅是硅谷，在整个行业中，招聘竞争非常激烈。即使经历了疫情，Adobe 的发展也非常快。从某些方面来说，疫情对 Adobe 来说……Adobe 是那种从疫情中受益的公司之一，对吧？现在每个夫妻老婆店都必须建立自己的网站并在网上进行电子商务，他们需要，你知道的，Photoshop、Acrobat 和我们的网页创作工具，他们需要用于广告的分析工具等等，而这些都是
the visibility in in the industry that say you you know, Facebook, Apple, Google, Netflix, the FANG companies, as the kids say. The FANG companies, yep. Yep, that the FANG companies have. So we tend to lose a lot of potential good hires to the FANG companies. And I think part of the issue there is that kind of outside of me talking at developer conferences, Adobe doesn't have a really strong presence in the C++ community or even in the broader just software development community. You know, if you go to the Vision AI, you know, SIGGRAPH areas,
所有这些都是 Adobe 销售的产品，嗯……嗯……所以因为竞争变得激烈，Adobe 在行业内的知名度往往不如，比如说，Facebook、Apple、Google、Netflix，也就是孩子们所说的 FANG 公司。FAANG 公司，是的。对，FAANG 公司所拥有的知名度。所以我们往往会把许多潜在的优秀招聘人选输给 FAANG 公司。我认为其中的部分问题在于，除了我在开发者大会上演讲之外，Adobe 在 C++ 社区甚至更广泛的软件开发社区中并没有真正强有力的存在感。如果你去视觉人工智能领域，
you know, Adobe has dozens of SIGGRAPH papers. They usually get submitted every year, and we have a strong presence in those communities, but not in kind of your, you know, day-to-day. We need a great C++ engineer to pull them in. And so part of the charter for this group is to raise external visibility for some of the interesting stuff that's happening at Adobe. And so I think you'll see, you know,
你知道的，比如 SIGGRAPH 领域，你知道，Adobe 每年通常都会提交几十篇 SIGGRAPH 论文，我们在这些社区中有着很强的存在感，但在你日常的……我们为了吸引人才而需要一位伟大的 C++ 工程师这种日常社区中却没有。因此，该小组的宗旨之一就是提高 Adobe 内部正在发生的一些有趣事情的外部知名度。所以我想你会看到，
both Dave and I speaking at conferences and promoting Adobe a bit and, uh, uh, trying to, to raise awareness and encouraging others at Adobe to also submit papers and speak at more conferences. Cool. So does this mean that we'll see, does this mean that Dave is returning to C++? Open-ended question. Maybe Adobe is switching to Swift. We don't know what the answer to that is.
我和戴夫都在会议上发言，宣传 Adobe 并试图提高知名度，同时鼓励 Adobe 的其他人也提交论文并在更多会议上发言。太棒了。那么，这是否意味着我们会看到……这是否意味着戴夫要回归 C++ 了？这是一个开放式的问题。也许 Adobe 要转向 Swift 了。我们不知道答案是什么。
Certainly, Adobe has a huge investment in c plus plus and and and a very large amount of code in c plus plus and so any answer to these problems has to include c plus plus so so there's going to be you know a a connection there um but at this point, we're not ruling out, you know, we're trying not to over-constrain the solution set, right? So, but yeah, I think, you know, Dave is going to have his hands more in C++, and it's very clear he's, you know, he kind of left the community pre-C++11 and so he's got a little bit of a culture shock stepping back in and just seeing how far C++ has moved in that time frame
当然，Adobe 在 C++ 上投入巨大，并且拥有非常大量的 C++ 代码，因此对这些问题的任何回答都必须包含 C++，所以肯定会有，你知道的，这方面的联系。但在这一点上，我们并不排除……我们尽量不过度约束解决方案集，对吧？但是，是的，我认为，你知道的，戴夫将在 C++ 领域投入更多精力，而且很明显，他，你知道的，他离开 C++ 社区时还在 C++11 之前，所以当他重新踏入这一领域时，看到 C++ 在这段时间内发展了那么远，他感到了某种文化冲击。
it's one thing to kind of be looking at the news articles it's another thing to kind of be looking at the news articles. It's another thing to be stepping into big code bases and going, wow, this has a significant impact in how people are writing code. Yeah, it's definitely evolved. One thing I was thinking, too, about the visibility is unlike Microsoft, which Bryce and I have talked about this on a past episode, Microsoft doesn't fit into the FANG acronym. But Adobe and NVIDIA, we could just have a triple A FANG and a double N, just make that acronym, and Adobe's logo is a legitimate A. I think we should make a new acronym for the cool C++ places. And so it would be Microsoft, Adobe, and NVIDIA.
光是看新闻报道是一回事，亲自踏入庞大的代码库并感叹“哇，这对人们编写代码的方式产生了重大影响”又是另一回事。是的，它确实在演进。我一直在思考的另一件事，关于知名度，与微软不同——布莱斯和我过去在一期节目中讨论过这一点——微软并不在 FANG 的缩写里。但 Adobe 和英伟达（NVIDIA），我们完全可以把它们凑成一个三 A 的 FANG，再加上两个 N，凑成一个缩写，而且 Adobe 的 logo 正好是一个正经的 A。我觉得我们应该为这些酷炫的 C++ 聚集地创造一个新的缩写。所以它会是微软、Adobe 和英伟达。
Now, there is one word that those spell, but it probably does not send the right message, the acronym to be MAN. We got to just add a couple letters. What word do we want to spell? We could spell AMAN. We could spell MAIN. We got to think of a cool word, reverse word do we want to spell? We could spell amen. We could spell Maine. We got to think of a cool word, reverse engineer it, and then just go find that or like go tell a company with that letter.
现在，这些字母拼出来是一个词，但它可能传达的信息不太对，这个缩写是 MAN（男人）。我们得再加几个字母。我们想拼成什么词呢？我们可以拼成 AMAN。我们可以拼成 MAIN（主干/主要）。我们得想一个酷炫的词，倒过来拼，然后去找出那个词，或者去告诉一家名字里有这个字母的公司。
Maine. I like Maine. What's a company with an I that rises to the same level of cool? I was thinking E, like the horse's Maine, but okay. Okay. Give me okay company with an E I guess Maine makes more sense because of the Maine branch on GitHub I don't know any companies that start with the letter I
Maine（缅因州）。我喜欢 Maine。有什么以 I 开头且达到同样酷炫级别的公司吗？我在想 E，就像马的鬃毛（mane）一样，但好吧。好吧。给我一个以 E 开头的酷炫公司。我想 Maine 更有意义，因为 GitHub 上有 main 分支。我不认识任何以字母 I 开头的公司。
we'll leave it to our listeners if you'd like to be in our new acronym tweet at us and you can be the eye or if you've got suggestions on extending our acronym is not going to be man i'll tell you that it'll be it'll be now yeah yeah well it's it's interesting because because uh adobe you know i think of adobe as being one of the old school like classic c++ shops because you know back in the, you know, I think of Adobe as being one of the old school, like, classic C++ shops.
我们把这个问题留给听众，如果你想加入我们的新缩写，给我们发推特吧，你可以当那个 I，或者如果你对扩展我们的缩写有什么建议——肯定不会是 man，我告诉你，会是……对，对。嗯，这很有趣，因为……因为……Adobe，你知道的，我认为 Adobe 是老派、经典的 C++ 公司之一，因为你知道，过去，
Because, you know, back in the day, you know, like A9 in particular, there was Stepanov. You know, Tony Van Erd went through Adobe. I think Niall Douglas was at Adobe. I don't know. Maybe it was Niall and Tony were both at BlackBerry. Louie was there. A bunch of, like, a bunch of old school C++ people went through Adobe. And it's got a big C++ code base.
我认为 Adobe 是老派、经典的 C++ 公司之一。因为，你知道，在过去，比如说 A9 尤其如此，有斯捷潘诺夫。你知道，托尼·范·埃尔德（Tony Van Erd）曾在 Adobe 待过。我想奈尔·道格拉斯（Niall Douglas）也在 Adobe 待过。我不知道，也许奈尔和托尼都曾在黑莓（BlackBerry）待过。路易（Louie）也在那儿。一大批，比如一大批老派的 C++ 人才都曾在 Adobe 待过。而且它拥有庞大的 C++ 代码库。
Sean, I recall you once telling a story that involved the number of lines of code and Photoshop and all the plugins. And I remember it was a surprisingly large amount of code. Yeah, yeah. We recently reran the stats. I don't have them at my fingertips here. But yeah, it's millions of lines.
肖恩，我记得你曾经讲过一个故事，涉及 Photoshop 及其所有插件的代码行数。我记得那是相当大的一笔代码量。是的，是的。我们最近重新跑了一下统计数据。我手头没有具体数字。但，是的，那是数百万行代码。
I don't think, unless you're kind of a professional Photoshop user, I think a lot of people don't have a full deep appreciation for just how much stuff is in Photoshop, right? I mean, Photoshop can edit videos, Photoshop can edit 3D. It's a very broad, broad product that gets used in a lot of different markets, both in graphics art and in science and engineering. So it's a very big and deep product. Thanks for listening. We hope you enjoyed and have a great day. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
我认为，除非你是一个专业的 Photoshop 用户，否则我觉得很多人并没有深刻地体会到 Photoshop 里面到底塞了多少东西，对吧？我的意思是，Photoshop 可以剪辑视频，Photoshop 可以处理 3D。这是一个非常广泛的产品，被应用在许多不同的市场中，无论是在图形艺术领域还是在科学与工程领域。所以它是一个非常庞大且深度的产品。感谢收听。希望你们喜欢，祝大家有个美好的一天。本期节目暂无评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可留下评论。